lui but on dévoile à paris sa nouvelle
acquisition un diamant brut de la taille
d'une balle de tennis
voici le sait où est l'eau ce qui
signifie découvert rare dans la langue
parlée au botswana au diamant a été
extrait l'an dernier avec un poids de
1758 carats soit environ 350 g
ces vélos s'impose comme le deuxième
plus gros diamant brut au monde après le
col hinan presque deux fois plus gros
qui avait été découvert il ya 115 ans la
pierre est encore cachée sous son
enveloppe de carbone noir mais elle sera
poli et taillé sur mesure pour des
clients de louis vuitton
le diamant pourrait ainsi facilement
valoir et de 80 millions de dollars
la minière canadienne lucas ratia
express diamant promet de consacrer 5 %
des revenus de vente à des projets
communautaires au botswana
[Musique]